good evening members uh welcome to the
licensing appeals committee 12th of
October
2023 uh first I need to read the
emergency evacuation announcement there
are no planned fire fire draws so if the
alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via your
nearest fire exit and form an orderly
queue behind me the fire exits are
through the main doors of the hall or
the store room adjacent to the stage the
fire assembly point is the island in
front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council
staff please note that the meeting will
be audio recorded uh please switch off
mobile phones or turn them to
silent toilets and handwashing
facilities are available in the foyer
area members your voice will only be
captured on the live stream when your
microphone is turned on so please
remember to switch on your microphone
when you're invited to speak and switch
off again when not
speaking members voting will be done on
a show of hands in line with the
Constitution I will ask for a show of
hands for and then against
recommendations and will'll also ask for
a show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from
voting so agenda item one is apologies
for absence and we have received
apologies from councelor Mrs Deborah
Squire Coleman councelor Roger conal
councelor Richard Lamour councelor Jack
laurman although he may make it later on
uh are there any other
apologies okay agenda item two
substitute members uh councelor Mrs
vilmer Wilson is substituting for
councelor Mrs uh Squire
Coleman agenda item three non-members
attending uh we have uh councelor
Angelina Marriot um but no other members
attending there's not a member here no
but she's a counselor so I thought as a
courtesy I would mention
it agenda item four uh the minutes of
the meeting held on 9th of March
members are those minutes
noted thank
you agenda item five to receive
Declarations of Interest are there any
Declarations of Interest
members agenda item six is uh the age of
private hire and Hackney Carriage
vehicles and I will now invite the
council's principal licensing officer uh
Mr Steven Greener to introduce this
report
good evening thank you very much this
report is to consider the amending the
existing Rocher District Council hanne
carriage and private hire licensing
policy 2022 to 2027 in relation to the
Age of Excess acceptable
Vehicles conditions
57.5 relating to the age of saloon
vehicles and 67.1 7 relating to the age
of wheelchair accessible Vehicles listed
in the rer district council haty
carriage and private hire drivers
vehicles and operators conditions
published in 2019 it states the vehicle
must not be more than six years old when
first licensed and will not be
relicensed if more than 10 years for a
salon vehicle and 12 years for a
wheelchair accessible vehicle age from
the date of registration the proposed
recommendation is to amend these
conditions to reflect the current cost
of replacement vehicles in the leadup to
the department uh the transports
secretary and business secretary
announcement to end the sale of new
petrol cars and diesel cars in the UK it
was by 2030 when I wrote the report but
then got changed to
20135 following this announcement the
cost of secondhand cars has increased
significantly so the two recommendations
that have been proposed is to amend the
minimum age of vehicles from the
existing 6 years wording to 6 years or
70,000 mil if older than 6 years from
the date of registration and the second
recommendation is to amend the relicense
limit from 10 years for a salon vehicle
and 12 years for a wheelchair accessible
vehicle to 12 years for a saloon vehicle
and 14 years for a wheelchair accessible
vehicle subject to the normal six months
checks and mots after the vehicle has
reached six years of a age from date of
registration I'm going to jump to the
background information according to
depart um auto trader and the latest uh
findings from the retail price index
which is based on daily pricing analysis
of 900,000 Vehicles revealed that the
average price of a used car has
increased by 32% year on year since the
last review of the conditions in March
2009 19 the cost of a secondhand car has
increased from an average value of
12,900 in March 2019 to
17732 in August to uh 2 uh
23 this increase equates to a difference
of an extra £
4,832 on the cost of a
vehicle and there's a chart showing
underneath the um prices index compared
to where it was
restricting the age limits of licensed
Vehicles this is reducing the scope of
suitable vehicles and by allowing this
amendment the trade will be able to
continue to keep a substantial level of
vehicles within the district appropriate
to the safety checks are being
maintained the Department of Transport
first issued their best practice
guidance in October 2016 to assist local
authorities in sorry
2006 um to assist local authorities in
England and Wales to have responsibility
for the regulation of Taxi and private
higher vehicle traits the section
relating to the a uh age limits State
age limits is perfectly possible for an
older vehicle to be in good condition so
the setting of an age limit Beyond which
a local Authority will not license the
vehicles may be arbitrator and
inappropriate but a greater frequency of
testing may be appropriate for older
vehicles for example twice yearly tests
for vehicles more than 5 years
old I have included some risks the risks
associated with this amendment is low
however over the last few years and the
running maintenance of the vehicles has
reduced considerably with the improved
engines and parts on more modern cars
but we are mindful that on the full
council meeting on Wednesday the 26th of
June rer District Council madej official
Declaration of a climate and ecological
emergency following the in the footsteps
of numerous other authorities addressing
the Urgent environmental challenges
facing the
world the Declaration confirmed the
council's commitment to achieving Net
Zero carbon status by 2030 for its own
estate and by 2040 for the Rocher
District area and to pursue e efforts to
achieve Net Zero CO2 emissions even
earlier and protect the enhanced
biodiversity I've also included under
the environment and climate implications
again the needs to be noted that this
will change the and to allow the
vehicles with higher emissions to
operate in the district for an
additional two years over the existing
restrictions cars registered from the
1st of September 2015 would meet the
Euro 6 cat rating but cars sold before
September
2016 may still have the Euro 5 engine
rating euro6 introduced lower acceptable
levels of nox emissions for Diesel's
cars to 80 milligrams per um kilogram uh
kilometer and for petrol is 60
milligrams per
kilometer that's it
from thank you Steven um
questions members I believe uh councelor
Williams had a
question yeah thank you chairman um
recommendation one um I'm not sure if
I'm reading that right to amend the
minimum age of vehicles should that not
be the
maximum we set a um minimum it should be
the maximum yes you're all correct yes
so the um we will we will not license a
vehicle the moment that is more than six
years old from the first time of
registration so it has to be younger
than six years old so yes it will be
maximum not minimum excellent thank
you counselor Mrs
mcferson thank you chairman um Steve on
uh page 6.3 um where you referred uh to
the guidance um that we can impose our
own sour sort of um
restrictions can you tell me how do we
sit with other authorities have they
already taken this step and sort of line
theirs up similar to ours and then I've
got a second question if that's okay um
it was in relation to the emissions on
older cars uh the figures that you've
you just read out I don't think they're
actually in the
report what what are we actually looking
at how how many more
do we get from these old cars how many
cars do you expect that sort of thing
please okay first of all in relation to
how do we compare with the other areas
um I'm not aware of any other reports by
any other Council so far in the local
area they've got a very similar sort of
age limit to us um but I know from
speaking to my colleagues in other areas
they are considering it because of the
cost of the secondhand car market um it
is worrying them that it May reduce the
amount of fleet vehicles certainly witer
accessible vehicles with their costs um
it's going to be a lot more difficult
and more expensive to
replace um so we are again very similar
to what we've done in the past we're
looking future planning as where this is
going um the trade certainly believe
that the cost of the second hand uh
secondhand car market is not going to
come down
significantly um bear in mind they are
trying to phase out the old old sort of
cars um so that's the first one um the
second one was in relation to um the
vehicles and the CO2 emissions um yeah
we are obviously Keen to try and get all
the vehicles over to eurocat 6 and by
still leaving the limit by having it as
14 years rather than leaving it
open-ended for wheelchair accessible
vehicles and 12 years that still
provides that top level cap so that we
are trying to then move to towards the
more modern cars all the
time thank you may just come back on um
yeah sure one part um when we were
talking about uh we're leading the way
with this really with other authorities
um where do we stand if theyve got older
vehicles are they then able to come to
us to license would we have an influx of
those or do they have to go back to the
same Authority that they've always
registered those vehicles
with no what we'll be looking at is we
um anyone can license a vehicle of any
type um and can we could see some
vehicles coming into us that have been
licensed somewhere else but they must be
of a good state of repair um and
suitable and also as well like to say if
uh for example we have a vehicle that's
eight years old but under 70,000 miles
they've still got that top limit of
either 12 or 14 years so it gives them
less period of time for use of that
vehicle um obviously the drivers are
keing to get as much use out of the
vehicles as possible so that's why we're
keen to push them to the younger
vehicles that they can get the longer
period of time that they've got to use
it rather than constantly replacing the
older sort of vehicles so but yeah no we
could get some older vehicles um but um
I would be very surprised if there are
existing taxes because of the amount of
miles that they do each year anyway um I
spoke to someone um only yesterday that
wanted to licens a six-year-old vehicle
and it had already done 98,000 Miles
because it has been a taxi somewhere
else so that that's why I've said the 70
limit um that's is a sort of an average
sort of use of a
car councelor
Stanley thank you chairman um I'm
somewhat confused as to this uh 70,000
miles as you already know we've got dual
fuel
vehicles so does that that mean 70,000
Mi actually clocked on the clock or does
that mean 70,000 Mi when it's running on
its engine and not on the
electric whether it be diesel or petrol
also
um my question to you is uh with
electric vehicles does that still
appertain of the 70,000 mil
and whether they are dual fuel Vehicles
as well thank
you yeah we will base it on the
information that is on the actual
mileage of the vehicle itself so we can
pull up the information from the
government site to actually see how many
miles of that vehicle is actually done
um so it is purely based on the mileage
of anot that tells us exactly what
mileage that they've done so regardless
of the type of vehicle so it could be
that we could get some of the older
electric vehicles come in that may have
done less than 70,000 miles that yeah
then we can then obviously issue that as
a license or it would be dual fued um
but it will still have to meet that 70
um the uh yeah 70,000 mile
limit yeah come back um I I I understand
what you're saying
but where we are with a net
zero uh by
2040 surely these electric vehicles
if they're kept in good order that
70,000 miles is couldn't can't be
applicable because there's no CO2 coming
out thank
you um I think there'll be obviously a
decision for the group is I think the
70,000 limit is for when they first
bring them on to First be licensed
whether you then allow them to have a
longer period of time at the end so
would you be happy to accept instead of
like the 12E limit at the end whether
you would allow them to have a longer
period for electric vehicles I don't
know that's down to committee members
and for yourselves to to discuss um I
put the 70,000 um limit in there so that
we had a Target to work to that an
average car if it was averaging about
12,000 miles a year so you're looking at
that sort of over fiveyear period or six
year period but obviously um that's why
we set that sort of Target sort of
figure um and the trait were quite
supportive of that Target figure that
they would then look for vehicles under
the 70,000 miles chairman can I just say
that no I'm sorry uh there's several
people wanted to ask questions councilor
Mrs
Wilson uh thank you chair um couple of
questions um my first one I think is
nearly M outt with that's the 7,000
pound uh 70,000 70,000 mile um limit I
was going to say is that because that's
average because the average is actually
dropped since coid has it so so that's
on that's on the generous side okay fine
I understand that thank
you with the um possible twoyear
testing uh presumably the first test
would be theot and the service in etc
etc but what would the second sixth
monthly of that year test be okay that's
what we do already at the moment so if
um someone was to license a brand new
vehicle with us and it was a hacky
Carriage um we don't ask for anot within
the first 12 months because it's
literally just come off the for cut um
for a hand Carriage but after 12 months
you will have to have anot every year
after it's reached its sixth birthday
then we do checks every six months so if
the vehicle was due in January we would
then ask to see the vehicle again in
July and then it's rolling every six
months that we would then do an
inspection on that vehicle um they must
get anot as part of that and then they
bring the vehicle in as a vehicle
inspection for ourselves in relation to
private hire um because they don't do as
many miles um if it was a brand new
vehicle um then we say um it doesn't
need anot for the first three years and
then it's yearly after that and then
again once it's reached its sixth
birthday then again it goes into the
category of having two tests every year
so they're six months apart and again
they would have to have an mot Within 10
days of the appointment with us and then
we do a physical inspection as
well okay Council
Williams thank you thanks for all me
back again chairman um Steve I wonder if
you could just tell me how many of our
licensed Vehicles do not yet reach the U
the Euro 6
rating would you
know no not off the top of my head um I
can have a look
um but that's going to take me a little
bit of time to export it out the system
I can do it if you want me to I just
wondering if you you a bit concerned
about about the emissions and if we let
them go a bit longer yeah like I say um
I think by still having the top limit I
think rather than leaving it open-ended
um I think that by having a limit it
then does force everyone to get into the
the eurocat 6 category um to be honest I
don't think there's going to be many
vehicles that going to have on there um
that have been licensed or registered
after the 1st of September 2015 because
we are almost not far off 2025 when they
all have to be replaced anyway um so
there's not going to be many that's
going to be on the system um but uh
there will be a few there'll be a
potentially there could be yes okay
thank you looking it councilor
Mo uh yeah looking at the industry
figures for prices uh obviously there's
something creeping up on us now that's
in the press in the last few weeks the
the price of electric cars is starting
to Tumble purely because there's new
salt and salt batteries sodium instead
of lithium and the price is drastically
dropping Tesla's led the way and they
reckon that the demise of the internal
combustion engine isn't far away because
when the car is cheaper have we
considered some sort of
incentive for people to go Electric in
with a secondhand vehicle um that fits
the criteria rather to encourage it
because the way things are going these
older vehicles that are skyrocketing
it's there there's going to be I I
believe a bit of a tumble soon so that
the extending this for 14 years might
become actually
meaningless yeah um it's it's difficult
one we can't really predict what's going
to happen um in relation to Grants and
funding I know it was originally when um
they first introduced the London sort of
black cab there was a lot of Grants and
funding that was available to licensed
drivers to to apply for it um but
especially bearing in mind the cost of a
Electric London cab I think it's I think
it's about 60,000 PS plus um so they had
a lot of Grants and funding put towards
them um initially there was grants and
funding available to licensed drivers
um and we offered that out we also were
proactive to get charging points put in
as well as part of the the grants um
there wasn't many that took it up um and
uh yeah I don't know if there is
currently any sort of Grants there's
nothing that we can physically do as a
department um around that because all
the money that comes into licensing has
to be spent in licensing so we can't
provide a grant system we're not legally
allowed to
um there may be something that our
economic development team might know
about um that may be able to assist them
um but there's not something that I
currently know of that's live at the
present time thank you Council
FD thank you chairman
um right just a quick one on what counc
Stanley was saying cars still have
suspension and brakes and everything
else I drive an electric car and they
still wear out the engine doesn't but
you still need to have so you use the
miles as a gauge on how the car's
wearing second I think this is going to
be a quite a mute point because in five
years time our roads are going to be
completely different than they are now
especially if electric cars come along
the way they will tax them will be
completely different it'll be per mile
because as you tax how much electric
you're putting in a car when you put
your care 120 times a day so I'm quite
happy to agree agree this but I think
we'll be looking at this again in the
next seven or eight years and you have a
complete
overhaul thank you councelor FD um
councilor
Ward thank you chairman um there just a
couple of things actually that that jump
out the report I think is excellent it's
very sensible i' I've got no complaints
whatsoever but the thing I'm I'm looking
at is what we are trying to do
uh do we have any
crossborder um views from Basildon uh
atford South End and all the other
licensing authorities will they be
following this because I mean obviously
we're looking to Net Zero within the
district but if we've got loads of taxi
cabs that are being licensed by other
burrowers and other areas that I see
running about all over the place all
over our district and they're not
following the same rules and they're
using older cars it's it doesn't
actually add up now are we talking to
those to follow these guidelines or are
they steering their own way so to
speak yeah under the legislation we each
um Authority in each district um makes
its own rules around vehicle licensing
which is we do speak and we speak
regularly I do um every two weeks I
speak to Basin South End um Brentwood
and Fark we're on a team's call and we
do discuss this um and one of the things
we have talked about is are we starting
to see less vehicles coming on um and
people not replacing Vehicles as much as
they were before so we've had the
discussion um I'm just quite proactive
and just trying to think ahead of where
it's it's sort of going um so that's why
when the trade approached me and said
look we've got a bit of a problem we've
getting new vehicles on um it was an
ideal opportunity to bring in front of
you to say look let's look at it discuss
it um it may be that um we don't at this
time and we delay it for a period of
time but the the stats have shown that
certainly in the last sort of couple of
years the cost of the secondhand cars
have gone up um and that the trade have
said to us we are struggling to replace
some of the vehicles so like I say we've
been quite proactive in the past with
some of our taxi stuff we've done and
hence the reason why I'm bringing this
forward now that
right yes okay Council Ward um I'm happy
to support this and uh if there's not a
proposal coming from the chair with this
I would like to make that
proposal uh one more question from
councelor mcf Mrs
mcferson thank you chairman it's
actually not a question it's a
recommendation if I have anybody who
will second it as the cat 7 comes in in
20 25 and I'm just looking at the
officer to confirm that I wonder if that
might be a good opportunity to have a
recommendation that we review this in
2025 does the officer want to comment on
that whether that's reasonable
recommendation thank you um yes I think
um I was just looking it up around the
Cat s sort of criteria you beat me to it
um but yeah no I think that'll be a
really good um it it sets us a benchmark
to then um sort of review it like I say
in 2025 we'll be in a better position by
then um we'll then know a little bit
more as well so
yeah okay so uh we need
to one more question from councilor
Stan thank you chairman I'm I'm somewhat
confused that that we're not dealing
correctly with and I know what councelor
FD as T said about vehicle Les being uh
brakes and and uh shock absorbers and
that sort of thing which would actually
pick up in mots in any case so that is
irrelevant I find um and as we're doing
a like anot every six months I still
find that irrelevant what I am saying is
that electric cars whether they are dual
fuel with electric or not I do feel that
if electric cars are being used then
they're complying with their
um carbon emissions that we're not gut
any carbon emissions so I would like to
like to see that the electric cars even
and and they are being moted after six
years in any case twice a year come to
that fact that electric cars should be
uh taken out of this equation and given
a little bit more time because uh I do
feel that
the the the companies that are putting
money into electric cars are are is
considerable and and they're looking to
the Future so we must I do believe that
we must encourage it uh to that extent
and and to look at that uh proposition
in in the long term that we've
got okay um councelor Mrs mcferson has
put forward an amendment we need to uh
discuss that if there are any questions
on that
Amendment sorry that recommendation I
mean yes we need to ask any questions on
the
recommendation um I think coming back in
2025 takes care of the electric car
issue because we can look at how the
situation is we've got another two years
to do it and and I don't think we're
going to have Deluge of electric cars
yet as they say maybe the price is
coming down but um there are a few
people who are now looking at the 2035
and saying not necessarily going to
change so quickly want to be able to see
a longer distance on batteries and
things like that so I think it's quite
safe to go with the recommendation 2025
I think it takes care of councelor
Stanley's concern about electric
vehicles and and I think that that's the
sensible approach and I would second
that or third it whichever way you want
to put
it okay if there's no more questions um
we need to go back to uh recommendation
one and uh there's a proposal to change
the chairman point of we need to vote on
accepting Council mcf's recommendation
to join the other recommendations in
vote okay so the um recommendation
number three is now to review this
decision in
2025 um you have a second already for
that so we need to take a vote on that
so all those in
favor that's unanimous thank you
[Music]
members thank you so um recommendation
one uh we need to change the wording
from minimum to maximum M can I have a
second for that uh Amendment
please councilor Shaw seconded yeah and
can we now well I'll move from the chair
that we now um vote on the three
recommendations so I wish to recommend
sorry so I'd like to move from the chair
the recommendations uh R1 R2 and R3 can
I have a second for that Council FD
thank
you so we'll take these um one at a time
um take them all together yeah
okay I'd like to do them separately
please okay thank you councilor
Wilson so recommendation one is to amend
the maximum age of vehicles from the
existing six-year wording to six years
or 70,000 miles if older than 6 years
from the date of registration all those
in
[Music]
favor any
against any
extensions thank
you uh recommendation two to amend the
relicense limit from 10 years for Saloon
vehicles and 12 vehicles from wheelchair
access vehicles to 12 years for Saloon
vehicles and 14 years for wheelchair
accessible Vehicles subject to six-month
checks and mots after the vehicle has
reached six years from the date of
registration those in
favor thank you those
against any
extensions thank
you and now recommendation three uh to
review this decision in 2025 all those
in
favor thank you that's
unanimous
okay um agenda item
seven Street trading policy consultation
uh members I'll once again invite Mr
Steven Greener to introduce this
report thank you um this is really just
a restart the application process that
we started back in September
2021 um in relation to updating and
amending the existing Street trading
policy um unfortunately with the way
things happen to the time the time
scales are very very tight which you'll
see further on in the report and
unfortunately they slipped so um I bring
it back to yourselves first of all to
have another look at the
um the draft policy um to see if there's
any sort of additions or changes because
there has been some some things that
have changed since we originally looked
at it um and also as well to then um
rece um ask for your permission to
restart the consultation to start the
process again so on the 30th of
September 2021 the licensing and appeals
committee considered a report to amend
the existing Street trading policy the
members expressed The View that there
was a significant step changing from
having specific roads designated for
Street trading to the proposed more
blanket approach and would be interested
to see the results of the public
consultation on the
policy a little bit of background
information on the 2nd of August uh
1995 the council adopted the provisions
of schedule four of the local government
miscellaneous Provisions act 1982 in
relation to consent streets the ACT
designates streets including Four Courts
roads footways and other adjacent areas
there to for a distance of 15 M as
consent streets and requires a license
for Street trading within the streets
under 2.3 I've listed the streets but I
fortunately it might be actually more
useful is I've also given you a sheet
which is the maps that I've actually
marked out all the consent streets on
the map because I thought it was easier
to
understand the existing policy has not
been reviewed since the council adopted
the provisions of the schedule 4 um of
the 1982
act what does a consent Street mean it
means a street in which street trading
is prohibited without the consent of the
council there is also what is known as a
prohibited Street which means that no
Street trading is uh Street trading is
prohibited from taking place within
those streets
there is a definition of Street trading
under the act and there are some
exceptions um that are not covered these
are a pedler holding a current Peddler
certificate and acting as a peddler
under the authority of the peders ACT
1871 a Trader that is part of a
authorized Market or Fair a Trader at a
petrol station a person trading in
association with an adjoining shop
premises so such as like grocers that
normally have like the food and stuff
just outside the front of the premises
it's that s of sort of business um a
trading in a trunk Road picnic area
provided under section 112 of the
highways Act of 1980 and then finally
Traders as a news vendor which is only
articles sold or offered for sale on
newspapers at periodic periods and
periodical periodical sorry thank
you there has been a number of changes
in legislation over the years and it's
been appropriate to ensure a policy is
fit for purpose and follows the most
upto-date guidance and
recommendations in summary these changes
relate to the adoption of further steps
to enhance safeguarding in streamlining
some of the administrative processes
around the renew and variations of
applications
and also to Greater regards to the
quality and needs to avoid
duplication under the
legislation I'm going to jump to
7.7 because it'll make it a little bit
easier as with every single policy there
are policy objectives which are set out
that we have to consider these are
Public Safety prevention of crime and
disorder um prevention of public
nuisance and protection of children from
home as I've already covered within
what's in scope and what is outside the
scope um under 7.9 I have outlined the
different types of um licenses that can
be applied for and which ones would
require a license and which ones
wouldn't so we have for example the A1
which is a single standard pitches which
is individual units for daily weekly and
quarterly or annual use um mobile
pitches these are Traders continually
moving from location to
location and um move at least 50 meters
from the last location and do not return
to that location at the moment it
stipulates for 4 hours and they do not
wait in one location for more than 30
minutes and do not trade ice cream Vans
are typically deemed to be um Street
Traders under this section unless it's
on pre-arranged appointments or
pre-arranged events event pitches are
organized block consents for units at
events within Rocher District Council
area farmers markets which typically
sell locally produced fruits and
vegetables craft markets and street
fairs and then um rer District Council
concession holders um which relates to
anything that is being held on Rocher
District Council
land um as we go on that um
7.13 talks about site specific condition
s um but again this is a good
opportunity to look at them and if you
think that um those are fit for purpose
or whether additional um conditions need
to be added then um we can then apply
those as
well going back to the report on
7.4 is around um paragraph 2.16 around
the proposed timetable as I've said
before um it is a very very strict
timetable that we have to comply with
under the legislation around the
consultation and I've got time scales in
there around when we look at starting
the consultation again um when we then
have to serve notices on the relevant
parties when the end of the consultation
then takes place then to consider any
representation then to produce a report
which will then come back into the
second um the um
licensing and appeals committee that
we've got early next year and then
following that decision to issue a
report and then we have to do public um
newspaper articles before the policy is
then
implemented we did do public
consultation when we first did it back
in um 30th of September
2021 um however the information was only
put onto the Russia District Council
website within the street trading Pages
unless you were specifically looking um
you wouldn't have seen it so much we did
do one or two um press articles about it
um but we only actually received one
response from a individual ice cream
vendor um asking more questions rather
than actually making
comments relevant risks um the risks
associated with this are still quite low
um however we do need to ensure that we
comply with the legal deadlines and the
governance of any sort of
amendments um we didn't identify any
equality or health
implications um but we did obviously
pick up around the environment and
climate implications there may be some
implementations or conditions that you
might want to add um around certain
types of um Vehicles if it's for ice
cream or what the um Traders can then
Supply certainly there's been new Chang
legislation about single use Plastics
and things like that that you may want
to include now within certainly the the
requirements and the
conditions and that's the end report and
any
questions thank you Stephen uh councelor
Mrs
Shaw thank you chairman thank you Steve
for a good report just one thing I've
seen the maps not can on there High
Street no it's only the the ones that
were actually adopted in 1995 so Canan
was never included in the original
consent and it can't be included now
this will be under the new structure
will cover every single Road within the
district all right thank you very much
for the
clarification councilor
Ward thank you Stephen again good report
I assume that the reds are noo
areas as as they should be
um just a couple of things actually um
just to go back on our previous uh
item where we're looking at the
possibility of let's say ice cream Vans
or any vendor a mobile vendor are we
going to be looking at the same kind of
conditions that we' put on taxes in in
regards to moving away from Petrol and
Diesel um that is certainly one of the
conditions that could be added on and
like I say when we originally looked at
the um Street trading um policy back in
um 30th of September 2021 I don't think
there was then a a limit that was going
to be set on vehicles around changing
over to electrics and stuff like that so
certainly yes that may be something that
you as a committee now want to add on to
say that the age of an ice cream vendor
cannot be more than a certain age or has
to be the Euro cap five six there's all
sorts of things that could be added as a
criteria if you feel that appropriate
and I can include that as part of the
consultation as well yeah I I if I may
come back sorry if I may come back I I
think we know that they're going to be
expensive these vehicles and they're
probably going to be more expensive than
any taxi on the roads to actually do
anything so we obviously need to give
them enough time to be able to change
over and know that we're going to expect
a change over so I mean whatever we put
in there it has to be
reasonable yeah absolutely and you can
stipulate by a certain by a certain date
that we will then um bear in mind that
the Street Traders license are renewed
each year um that we could advertise it
early enough to say by a certain
deadline that all the vehicles has to
meet them with this criteria and work
towards that date so yeah it's something
that you can add on do you want to come
back councilor yeah thank you um well I
mean obviously the government has Set uh
2035 um we need need to need to
understand what the costing of this is
going to be for them as much as anything
and what is going to be reasonable um I
have no idea I've just seen this and
obviously looking at what we looked at
previously I haven't got a clue how much
a vending vehicle cost but it's going to
be very expensive I would imagine with
everything in it so um you know this is
something we need to look at reasonably
as as a living for somebody and make it
not too honorous but
reasonable I have no idea and no
suggestions as the time I'm sorry about
that I can't give you one unless someone
else wants to throw one in I can sort of
try and help you out with that one as
much as I can as I've said um we have to
now do another public consultation um
and I will be Keen to make sure I send
the new sort of draft out to every ice
cream vendor that use is used in the
area um through that consultation if we
suggest a certain age limit and put that
in the document and then they come back
to us and say actually it's going to
cost 60 70,000 to replace a vehicle at
least when we come back and look at it
again early next year you will hopefully
have those stats and those figures to
then make that decision as to whether
you make minor changes or major changes
to the policy at that time I think
that's very reasonable yeah councelor
Mrs
mcferson thank you chairman um perhaps
it could be along the lines of 2025 that
we're looking for a cat six for ice
cream Vehicles there's just a thought
there if um we want to set a
deadline I didn't have any questions on
this until you did your piece um so just
to confirm these red lines are the old
areas and now we're going to Encompass
everywhere in the district that's
correct the red lines are the current
consent
roads that need the consent licenses um
that was agreed originally in
1995 my proposal is to cover every
single Street um and then there's
certain types of licenses I don't think
that we need to cover like I say if it's
a wellestablished market already then
that doesn't need a license but if
there's a popup market then yes they
would need it um if someone and we had
quite a lot during coid funny enough a
lot of people were doing sort of popup
boot cells on their driveways um then
again I've excluded the personal um sort
of properties and private dwellings so
they wouldn't need then a Street Traders
license to just find that balance um but
it's a step to getting um sort of more
regulated around the Street Traders that
are working within the district thank
you um I remember that well because that
was in my area and you worked with them
the group um I would say a definite yes
to include the restriction on single use
Plastics please and hopefully everybody
else is in agreement with that and my
only upper question sorry chairman is
around
alcohol alcohol will still have to
follow under the licensing act and they
would have to still apply for any
temporary event notices um if they were
looking at selling anything at any
Street
stalls and same for late night
refreshment um any food that's being
sold after 11:00 at night will still
also need a street um a um alcohol
license uh councelor
Stanley thank you chairman uh couple of
things that haven't been put in there
and to exclude that would be uh schools
and um bazars and that sort of thing uh
which we haven't excluded um the one
thing
we've noticed um when we talk
about
uh ice cream sailers and what have you
we've also had in the past um vendors at
the market in ra um that sell um cooked
if you like uh dishes I should put that
because they're Italian or they could be
anything sort of thing but a lot of them
do have generators and and I wonder if
that should not also be included in the
proposal for the ice cream Sellers as
well to to get them to either put in
solar or something like that recently we
have had somebody who has uh applied for
a license I believe for um uh ice cream
vendor if you like who would who's given
it up as you remember I do distinctly
remember remember this and he said that
uh a v ice cream van for electric would
only be used for four hours at a Max
when it's fully loaded and that the cost
would be well in the
hundreds of thousands so I wonder if we
can somehow I don't know how we would
but to extend that on further uh and and
unless they've got some sort of solar
power or or that sort of um help with
the generating of electricity to the
vendor um I don't know if that can
happen in in relation to what we're
asking here
tonight um yeah going back to um the
individual um that I've spoken to quite
a bit around obviously the the plans and
how it's moving forward and around how
much it costs to convert to electrics
for um ice cream vendors um what we did
have a conversation about was whether
you could actually have a generator
actually self-sufficient inside the
vehicle that isn't then riant upon the
electrics from being drained from the
the vehicle itself um there are options
there are ways of doing it um they are
looking into that and they're going to
be coming back to me so that will be
tiing very nicely with the consultation
sort of aspect um in relation to the
schools we have got something in there
under 7. n um at the top in relation to
um that they will not trade within 100
meters of the boundary of any school or
college between 7:30 and 8 um 6 o'cl
without formal in um invitation from The
Establishment themselves so again that's
to then try and address some of the
issues with the ice cream Wars no that's
right um so no um again we've had some
ice cream war situation we've been
working with V police as well um I think
I got asked this question last time so
I'll cover it now because I remember it
got brought up um how are we going to
regulate ice cream vendors working in
the entire District um the way of doing
that is under the application form we
will have um all the wards and then
there'll be asked to choose free Wards
in which they would want to work and
then they'll apply for those fre Wards
and then we'll work it out and we'll
balance it out so everyone has got areas
to try and stop the ice cream Ward areas
so that's how we will balance that out
chairman I was the reason that I brought
that up was that the the ice cream
vendors are generally no more than about
5 MERS from the front door of the of the
schools so thank you for
that Council
Williams yeah thank you chairman um I
think I'm not sure if this is right but
the Chimes on ice cream Vans are now
deregulated there is no maximum volume
um and I'd like to know if that could be
included that they are um in particular
the Teddy Bears Picnic driving me crazy
um it's I'm getting earworms with it
it's but seriously they are very loud
now and I just wonder if they could be
included I'll include that within there
and ask if our Lea we environmental
health as well around the suitable Des
spell level thank
you councelor Stuart
Wilson thank you chairman it's a very
quick question really um recommendation
one is to agree the timeline as outlined
within the report how confident are we
that we can achieve the milestones in
this um we are very keen on it um
because we're also being pushed by Essex
police that are very keen nit as well um
they've had lots of issues over the last
12 months around anex behavior and like
I say there's lots of issues around the
ice cream vendors that's the key one
that I'm really Keen to get through very
quickly
um yes I will be hot on it this and we
have to reach and meet all the deadlines
and we will do um it's just been pointed
out to me that we may have to schedule
another meeting in just to make sure
that the time is all marry up um but
we'll do that um because I'm very keen
to move this one forward
okay councilor
M um I do know something about selling
ice cream in that running large Fates
and functions when I was a chairman of
the joint Scouts management and all that
it's not necessary to have a generator
going in one of these soft ice cream
machines because I I was able to go to
the wholesaler and pick up a raming
great trailer that was full of prepacked
ice cream and you could put together
waivers and things but it was super
insulated even in a hot day so you could
insist otherwise you're going to get
people parking up pumping diesel fumes
all over somebody's house and everything
opposite of school every day so their
air quality is going to be really down
there uh whereas the ice cream vendor
could just as easily sell lollies and
the type that go in the blocks prepacked
you haven't then got a hygiene problem
which you do get with these soft
machines and and I don't think there's
any lithium packs around that were run
them for very long these
days unless in the High Street we
provided a post where they have to pay a
bit of a rental to plug in I mean we
could do that but it's not necessary or
we might even do it outside of school
but the council could charge for that
but we need to look at that because we I
think we have to come back and look at
this because the technology might move
on it doesn't look like it at the minute
but they can sell ice cream they don't
have to have a machine chugging way to
do it and we could insist on that and
it's clean yeah absolutely it'll be
really interesting to see the the
comments from and the trade as well um
around it um if um they throw sort of or
put blockages in the way then we need to
look at like I say how to make it more
um environmentally friendly so yeah
that's um so you talk about it was an
extra trailer that they had on the back
that was then able to but these people
can pick up the whole packs like that
for their fridges in in the in the
vehicle because they're just super
insulated thing with a lid on the top um
you do get some ice cream vendors have
that and don't have the soft and there's
no fumes or anything from them so it's
not necessary for them to do that and
have some slop going around with a
machine chugging away pumping out carbon
dioxide okay okay thank you we couldn't
insist on that in certain locations
because I think Council cross raised
this business with people with diesel
engines running and everything all day
long all afternoon it's not good yeah I
was going to say especially in the same
location um I think we should insist on
engines being switched off whenever
they're in a static um position and in
the absence of a trailer with a with a
prepack um councelor Mill I think we
could uh they can put that in the van
because they've got the they've got the
cool boxes to put in the Vans yeah is a
problem if they can't get them in the
van for whatever reason I think uh we
could insist that they switch the
engines off and have a a battery an
inverter if necessary to power the the
fridge I think solar panels are not
powerful enough to to provide Power for
the uh for the fridges but a a chunky
battery and an inverter could easily
work for that time when it's stationary
and the engine switched off that's
that's my input chairman if I may
interrupt you there there are points
that thank you councelor Stanley um we
have some other questions councelor Shaw
is next with with with a question I'll
come back to you if we we have have
time thank you chairman um as Steve said
7.9 on the mobile pitches we have uh
vendors ice cream vendors that are
actually already right outside the
schools typically on Ashton Road and
they do go outside
on Canon against the school there so how
are we going to actually this is all
very well saying they shouldn't do but
they're doing it already so how are we
going to actually police
this yeah the enforcement is going to be
key to it um and that's down to us as a
department that we will be out there
enforcing it I'm sure we'll get told by
other vendors if um someone is breaking
the rules um and we'll I'm sure we'll
get photographs and things that we'll
then take formal action like we do with
all of our normal sort of licenses
around Hackney carriage and everything
else but that's going to be key um is to
make sure compliance with the
regulations that we will be doing that
thank you
Steve councilor Mrs mcferson thank you
chairman um I think it's quite um um sad
that this is still rumbling on because
these um uh Waring ice cream men have
been going on for years um so just a
thought when we're talking about keeping
track on where they are um could we not
have them voluntary um part of the
license have a Tracker in there they're
not expensive
then they can prove where they are and
that they keep within their set Wards
and they're not parked outside
schools so that was just a
recommendation thank you
chairman do you want to come back on
that yeah I can add that as one of the
conditions like you say a lot of
vehicles nowadays have trackers they're
not expensive they can be wired in so um
I include that under that section around
mobile
Vehicles Council award
thank you chairman uh I was reminded of
something years and years ago 50 years
ago that um councelor mil came up with
and this was quite prevalent I remember
I used to see them as a kid they used to
be ice cream sellers with a trolley he
just had a box he had nothing on a
bicycle exactly exactly and he had a cap
on you know and you had your block and
you had your wife and all the rest of
this stuff now what made me laugh I'm
sorry I had to laugh in thinking about
that because there was a sorry of bring
a little bit of humor into it but there
was a cartoon in punch and you know how
these various things go along there was
a guy in like this mask and the normal
striped soup and he had a pistol and he
came out he jumped up and robbing people
and then he came the ice cream salesman
came along and on the front of it has
got stop me and buy one so he's having
the the crook is now having to get money
out to actually buy an ice cream I just
thought I want to thr it was quite
amusing but it was that same thing
whereby you know they had all the ice
creams and the cones and such like and
they didn't have an engine they didn't
have anything it was in there so there's
no reason why you cannot have an
insulated box that goes in there to sell
not going to be out to do the the
whippies but there'll be the other ones
thank you councelor ward I guess you
remember the day of Molly Malone when
she pedal cockles and muscles from her
Barrow as
well councelor
Stanley yeah they used to have great big
ice blocks in the bottom of those as
well um as the if you go to South End
where they've got a distribution point
where everybody plugs into if you you've
obviously know that in any case I wonder
if the I don't know if the life if
licensing department can work that in
with the uh 's County Council so that
you know so that we're moving on into
the new era of plugging in rather than
have the engine running or Diesels or
generators or whatever they can just
plug in I don't know if we can move into
that area thank you I have to admit I
don't know either um but I can look into
it um are Lea with with economic
development with um Essex highways I
deal with them a lot anyway around
pavement permissions and things like
that so I can do some dig and I'll try
and find out and come back to
you thank you members if there's no more
questions uh I'd like to move from the
chair that um uh the recommendations as
set out within the report um are voted
upon do I have a second thank you
councilor
Stanley so can we take these two
recommendations in one
vote thank you
members so uh all those in favor of the
two
recommendations thank you that's
unanimous agenda item
the allocation of new licensed driver
slots under the earn as you learn scheme
uh members once again I'll invite Steven
Greener to introduce his
report okay um last report
so uh if you remember back in um March
the licensing and appeals committee
reviewed the effectiveness of the energy
learn scheme that we introduced to try
and encourage new
drivers at the time there was a debate
around the issue of the number of the
energy learn badges issued to operators
within the district and some members
considered it appropriate to put um in
place an overall figure of the number of
Badges of 40 and sharing it out amongst
the energy learn drivers rather than
limiting the number available to taxi
operators other members however believe
that the same number of ear you learn
badges should be given to each taxi
operator in the interest of
fairness the recommendation is to amend
the restriction on um two of The
Operators which is best tax and Andrew's
allocation of new applicants from 10 and
increase it to 15 and share the
remaining 10 slots between the other two
operators associated with the scheme on
a first come first surf basis and then
to conduct a full review of the scheme
again at the next licensing and appeals
committee so the reason for this is that
we were approached by the two main
operators covering the russer district
they have taken full advantage of the
scheme and the popularity has meant that
they've been forced to turn away new
applicants and again what I gave you on
your sheet on your table is the number
of um drivers that are under the current
scheme and also as well their EXP exp
iry
dates so as you can see from the sheet
um that Andrews and bestx have used
their allocation um at the time that I
produced this export um someone passed
their knowledge test today so that's why
Andrews has dropped down to nine rather
than 10 um whereas the r Cooperative
have got two so at the moment there's 21
drivers that are currently going through
the earn as you learn SC scheme at the
present time and the earliest at the
moment that um anyone is going to be
dropping off the scheme is going to be
in February
so um at the time when we first
introduced the scheme there was a
national licens driver shortage
following the pandemic whereby the
number of drivers found alternative
employment and decided not to continue
the trade following a meeting with the
operators it was identified that
requirements to at the time to obtain
the hat and carriage driver's license
took approximately 6 months before the
driver could start work for those who
were seeking employment in the trade
they would have to take this timeline
into consideration with the knowledge
that that they may not work for up to
six months whilst they complete the
application
process so as it's been mentioned
already um that these two operators have
been very very proactive in um
recruiting new drivers whereas two of
The Operators haven't been as
proactive um and therefore they have
asked for their allocation for Andrews
and best tax to be increased to 15
instead of their current limit of 10 and
then the five uh sorry the 10 remaining
so still keeping the 40 will then be
shared equally between the ra
cooperative and Alpine on a first come
first serve basis any questions
any questions members councilor FD thank
you chairman good report as always
Stephen um still going to be 40 badges
this they've had how long since we
reviewed this last uh it was in March
this year so they've had six months
they've said six months of putting this
scheme through its paces and this is
where we at we've got two very proactive
and two not so proactive so personally I
feel the proactive one should be
rewarded so we don't want to turn people
away so I'm quite happy to support this
yeah and like I say it's still to keep
the limit at 40 as well not to extend
that
limit councilor
Williams yes thank you chairman um I
understand that the are scheme has been
um extremely popular um and we the Envy
of many other licensing authorities so I
will like to say that I would support
this fully thank
you thank
you councelor
Stanley thank you chairman um as I
remember um there was a motion
that this shouldn't be restricted to an
operator of 10 badges as I remember uh
and you've got that down there and we're
looking at it again as to being
nonrestricted to 10 but a maximum of 40
I just asked I'm going to ask the
question why are we doing that now when
we could have done that six months
ago um going back from my memory from
the meeting and I've included the
minutes in there there was a motion like
I say to have it as a pull of 40 um but
that wasn't then supported at the time
and then there was another hit the
microphone there was another motion then
to then limit it to 10 per operator
which was then approved at that time so
yes um that was agreed that each
operator would then have 10 but as we've
seen and the figures have shown two of
The Operators haven't used it fully
compared to the other two um I'm King
still to keep the same limit of 40 um
but it then gives these two that have
been proactive that little bit of a
boost a couple more spaces but still
allows the other two that haven't been
proactive an opportunity to still bring
drivers on all
right councilor w
thank you stepen that has been perfectly
explained because I knew nothing about
this until I read the papers and I
looked at the minutes and everything
that had gone through so yeah 40 sprit
between four was 10
each two have done their job the other
two haven't and so you rewarded the ones
who have done the job thank you all
explained fully supportive
oh that's
good councilor
boo I just want you to clarify are we
really talking about a maximum of 30
though if we've got two companies that
aren't going to take up the 10 that are
left because we've only or a maximum of
32 if the co-op actually takes two of
those 10 so what happens to the 10 or
the eight that might be sitting there
that the other two companies don't take
up yeah if they don't decide to use it
that's down to them
um we obviously brought it in at the
request of all four operators it was the
original request by all four at the time
when I had a meeting with them um like I
say two have been very proactive and
recruited um two haven't been as
proactive um but I had an email from
certainly one of the operators to say we
have had mainly their focus was in the
South End area but they're starting to
grow the business in the ra area so they
wanted still rather than to be excluded
completely to still have some scope to
then bring people on um but by and this
still allows them to do that Council
Booth you want to come back on yes thank
you chair for the second question so is
the plan that we keep on reviewing this
every six months or is there a longer
period review
now uh it was agreed at the last meeting
that we would review it next year um in
accordance with the minutes that was at
the time um then we will have a look at
the figures all the information around
the jobs that have been allocated out
how much work the drivers have been
doing whether the committee then want to
continue with it or whether it's time
that we've actually reached the Target
that what we want to achieve and we will
then stop it um but that will be a
certainly a discussion for the um
scheduled event uh scheduled meeting for
next
year councilor
mil yes yes a question for Steven yeah
the um in consultation with the
operators because I know that prior to
the pandemic just get background they
were moaning from taxi drivers CU I used
to use them a lot don't use at all since
the pandemic and um that there were too
many drivers and they couldn't make the
living they wanted so obviously there
would be so their estimate this is what
we base this on what they thought they
could take as a reasonable amount for
the number of drivers to get a service
and that that's how we arrived at that
figure yeah yeah it was a bit of a
balance around everything to be honest
um we didn't want to overload it with
too many new applicants um when we ran
the scheme last year um we had it
open-ended um and I think we've learned
from that as a group um that that um was
actually causing problems with existing
drivers because that was then
compromising their work they were then
actually struggling themselves and then
we were actually it was having the
reverse effects we were actually losing
more drivers because there wasn't enough
work out there um by bringing in a limit
um that then sort of gave the confidence
to the existing drivers that we weren't
going to suddenly just flood it with new
drivers and allow those was a bit of a
balance with the amount of work um
compared to the figures in 2018 um we
are still a lot less than what we were
in 2018 um but I was again I was talking
to a driver this morning um and he was
saying how busy or it looks very busy
with drivers out there at the present
time back in 2018 everyone or a lot of
people were going commuting to London um
by train they were going out socially on
a Friday and Saturday night um there was
a lot more use of Southend airport the
taxi trade was very very busy since the
pandemic a lot of people are still
working from home so they're not going
out as much um so the the number of sort
of calls that they're getting did drop
for a period of time that's starting to
now increase as businesses are now
starting to force people back into the
offices again and we've just got our
role is to make sure that we've got
service out to the public um by keeping
it still at the 40 The Operators are
happy with it it's working the drivers
the existing drivers are happy with it
um but this just gives them the extra
sort of five of where they're turning
people away it just means that they're
not losing sort of good new drivers that
want to come through thank you so we're
managing a healthy business isn't this
for them that's the important thing the
yeah I'm all for
this any more questions
members okay um I wish to move uh the
recommendations One and Two from the
chair or recommendation one from the
chair can I have a second please
councelor
stand okay all those members in
favor unanimous that's unanimous thank
you members
um so I'd also like to move um
recommendation two from the chair can I
have a second for that counc Council boo
thank you uh all those members in favor
of recommendation
two that's unanimous thank you
members thank you members that concludes
the business for this evening meeting is
closed at uh
2046 I would say thank you and good
night